[Music]
protesters defied a mandatory curfew
president pedro castillo imposed the
measure late on monday protesters said
it infringed on their freedom police
tried to contain the people's anger
they used tear gas as thousands of
peruvians demanded castillo's
resignation
many had come to rally peacefully with
children and the elderly joining the
demonstrations
antonio portugal says he'll protest
until castillo is ousted
i'm so angry we cannot have this kind of
a president we have to put pressure on
him to live and to live now
stores schools and markets remained
closed for most of the day the army was
deployed to some districts pedro
castillo was under pressure and lifted
the curfew six hours before it was due
to end
the spike in fuel food and fertilizer
prices was too much even for the
president's former supporters
poor peruvians whose hopes were raised
when he came to power last year are now
turning their backs on the government
the truth is that castillo has to leave
because he's inept this is not a
government out with him
the president met lawmakers to find a
solution to the crisis but left without
announcing any plan
the situation is getting more tense in
the streets of the capital as the hours
go by with protesters throwing rocks at
police and police responding with tear
gas now these are a series of protests
that began a week ago and many believe
that they will continue
[Music]
whatever castillo decides to do next
protesters here say they are fed up with
a president who's not fit to govern
mariana sanchez al jazeera lima peru